hey I'm Tiffany Smith and I'm Kristian
harloff and our guest today he's a
writer he's a comedian and he's producer
it's Jay Larson and this is movie except
I won again
box office let's get into it oh yeah can
you like actually let the show get
started no you start Brad started
all right well since you brought it up
at the beginning of the show let's just
get this loser [ __ ] out of the way what
does the loser job for this week guys
already I'll tell you what it's gonna be
Tiffany talks to guests I'll do that
right now
let's [ __ ] chase them what are you
doing we're gonna do a little drinking
game I think you're familiar with my
show best bars in America yeah I figured
I'd come along I bring the cup look at
that you bring that beer that's that is
right now you're gonna get a high C
classic high C pitcher of beer I mean
this is like what every mom would have
so what we'll do is we'll do a little
drinking thank ya we can each maybe come
up with the rule okay how about this is
my rule every time Christian says a word
wrong okay done how about every time
Tiffany last one she's not supposed to
hey that's on there's no reason for you
to laugh because we're shooting you you
ever be honest here I bet they were both
drinking
anyone who's 21 can drink with us at
home I remembered home don't drive drunk
it's just stupid
it's literally stupid okay we were
talking before we started filming
actually and we were talking about the
critics award what about the winners
everything that happen if there's anyone
in there that you thought shouldn't one
could have won I think the Critics
Choice Awards kind of like they're just
like who do we want their awards won
with an MVP award yeah Schumer get VP
Award and spotlight won the award for
Best Picture last night do you guys
think that means it could possibly win
the Oscar as well I mean I think you
can't not look at the Critics Choice the
words thank you very much for refilling
all your own okay yep well you do it
every week what's different this week
have you looked
since 2011 of the films that won for
Best Picture at the Critics Choice and
won the Oscar Wow so it's definitely
momentum in the right direction if you
win the Critics Choice Award J yes or no
spotlight wins Oscar this year yeah give
it to him - I'm gonna say yeah I
wouldn't be surprised the revenant did
it but yeah I think spotlights gonna win
and J you guys were critics stop sucking
up to the critics because you are
actually doing a movie right imitation
the invitation comes a little March
let's talk about it what is it
ironically it's a thriller but the same
ride as it did right along and right
along - wrote it like an ensemble cast
this is about 12 us with some great
actors I literally had no right being in
this set you know I mean I was the
comedic relief if you will and I
relieved
I really have but it's now it's an
intense movie did you have hesitations
going in from having the community
bright background into doing a thriller
I had hesitations coming here today yeah
well Jay is winning he's winning at life
you are losing every week here at the
box office wager that we do Jay if
you're not familiar with this every week
the movie that's coming out what are the
big movies with bet on it and Tiffany
loses at least in 2016
every week I would like to emphasize
that every week is only to choose more
than nothing officially on a streak -
sounds like a street last week we bet on
ride-alongs - I bet 39.5 you bet 41 the
actual number was 34 million which means
this week's punishment comes from Chazz
urchins 5,000 on YouTube loser should
wear 20 sweaters and job in place for at
least one whole segment who has the time
to make his youtube name jazz or tense
and 5010 and they can't spell jog
it's a letter bro you realize it's a
consonant in place so I am jobbing in my
seat are you ready for the loser shirt
or not perfect we store a weekly wager
on the fifth weave I think this week
because 10 million million opening
weekend okay I'm gonna go 12 the books
did so well a lot of people love Chloe
it looks action-packed there's nothing
really that's in direct competition with
this our experts pick I don't think even
title yourself an expert but I just if
he has 28 million will know I like to
find out what the hell's going on with a
loser should this week you got a sweater
ready one sweater
okay well oh okay make sure you guys do
send in your loser sheds use the hashtag
loser should in the comments below on
Twitter and on Facebook and we're going
to Sundance next week so make sure you
do your come you don't get to come you
don't come no it's just
make sure your loser shows our sundance
related for this week and now I love
hearing about people's top film so what
are your top five favorite comedies I'd
say one is easy for me it's big lebowski
that's my favorite I am NOT mr. Lebowski
you're mr. Lebowski I'm the dude I like
to go old-school Farish feels day off
Bueller Bueller I like things that are
in line without what I like I like tin
cup okay
Oh who's that come on nobody can copy
things you're common you don't think tin
cups a comedy not is it kind of a last
scene is the drama all in itself it but
just because there's drama in it doesn't
mean are in comedy okay
Caddyshack man I didn't seek out yet
your stolen CK I never never like I
never start to finish and guess what
happens when you didn't see something
you were kid it's like skin you can't
just go pick up skiing when you're in
your late 30s catty sack and wash it oh
we're friends let's talk about some of
the upcoming comedies that we're looking
forward to I for one am very excited
about Zoolander 2 I just wanted to run
around yelling orange mocha frappuccino
which I already do but I'll do it even
more when the second movie comes out zoo
- yep well for me I'm looking forward to
the disaster artist which is if you
don't know about the cult movie the room
which is one of the worst movies of all
time but still was able to just build
this cult following there's an actor who
wrote a book about what it was like to
be on that set James Franco bought the
rights to it and Evan Goldberg and Seth
Rogen are producing it Christian's
talking about a documentary like a
comedy it's undocumented comedy about
the making of this movie called the room
yes he is not talking about the Oscar
fulfill room which was hilarious the
room the actual film is a comedy in
itself I love the fact there's the one
scene where it's like the lead actress
decided she only wanted to do the one
sex scene so they read it's in other
parts of the movie phenomenal it is such
a mess the things that happens a guy has
a beard in one scene in the next shot
he's all clean shaven it's awesome
alright so another one that I'm looking
forward to this
Hail Caesar yeah oh yeah : brothers I
mean it looks awesome let me tell you
something I love the Coen brothers but
guess what I'm I'm gonna throw you
another curveball I didn't like oh
brother we're out though
and I feel like this is gonna be in the
same vein I'm feeling I'm getting a vibe
you ever get vibe yes I'm getting by
like I gotta fight when I came here
today and I was right not Greg and then
I'm getting a vibe when I just see that
oh my god it's probably gonna be a
little oh brother where art thou e all
right to each his own it's true it's
true and I'd like to be surprised by
something I think is gonna be bad and
then it turns out to be good so like
when you're coming on our show so much
with this but with other things you know
it's trying to get you to say something
nice about being on the show today
because I'm about to say something nice
about you thank you so much for joining
us on Jay Larson comedy oh there is oh
boy
nice oh look the sweaters are finally
here at the end of the show perfect all
right let's just end the show yeah let's
do that
okay clap your hands it's embarrassing
alright guys make sure you click
subscribe to our chick so be here thank
you subscribe over there
unbelievable and make sure you look for
past episodes right there and then you
also download the Fandango movie clips
up on your smartphone and you guys get
it really excited because next week's
movie threesome is gonna be at Sundance
all right
we're ending the show because this is
movie break is enough